foreign
[Music]
anyone who doesn't have one
I suggest you
spend a little more
and not by
too cheap about
so that you get a nice depth of sound
my bowel was bought in Japan
in the city of Mito
just outside from Irma a short train
distance
[Music]
and nowadays with the internet
Amazon worldwide
and another
ways of purchase United's
if you can afford it
I recommend you
spend it
not a silly amount of or how are you
but but
as I say don't go for just something
that looks nice
there's many bra spells out there and
some have a nice sound to them
problems Personnel I find better
you can get crystal glass ones
and sometimes
good
shops in the UK even
but anywhere in the world nowadays shops
specialize in these things
so first of all
if you can say yourself
going back onto the storm
in your mind
getting comfortable
closing your eyes
and we're going to visualize
your imaginary bowel that you've bought
place to hear that in your life and palm
up
with the cushion that it normally comes
with you will need a cushion
but the Bell sits on to get the right
vibration
place it in
only favor the most
and hold it not against your chest but
but perhaps your forearm the side of it
resting
on your
body
and you can even do this action
if you don't yet have a bell
and we'll imagine it in some place the
arm that you feel comfortable with our
mum
if you haven't been already then
it needs to be placed but when you sit
down obviously and then place it on your
Palm holding it and take the striker in
the opposite hand
calm yourself before you strike it
if you just strike it
is like a child with a new toy
it doesn't have any value it just has
excitement
excitement is no good for this process
we need depth
so I'm going to do the same
with my balance
as I talk you through yours
so first of all
towards the top of the edge of the bowel
by the outside
we're going to strike it
you can keep your eyes open if you wish
or you can position where the striker is
roughly with your eyes open
when you know you're going to hit and
then you can slowly close your eyes
if you didn't
hear the last
film on
how to calm yourself you need to sit
there and check your breath with your
eyes closed
to see how calm your breath is
you shouldn't help the breath if you
think it's too fast or erratic
the body needs to calm down on its own
it means that you're having things on
your mind or you didn't realize perhaps
that you were as struggled As You Are if
you're breathing is erratic
High deep
or anything other than
calm
your breath should end up
almost fairly as if it's not going in
and out
of your nostrils
some people breathe in through the
nostrils out through the mouth
I nowadays prefer to just
in and out through the nostrils
and allow the jaw
to just fall open so there will be a
small hole in your mouth
because if you hold your lips together
you may hold tension
but you must find what is comfortable
for you not what is comfortable for me
it's a very individual process
because we're trying to get
each one of us to us place
that we're happy with not what a matter
is
as I ring the bell I'll do it just once
just so that
you can hear it and then I will talk
about what to do before you do it so
with your eyes closed imagine you're
sitting on the stall imagine that you're
holding the Bell
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay I stop the bowel from continuing I
place my finger on the top at the edge
the next time I bring it
I want you to keep listening to the
sound but think of
like being as if you were in a lift but
on the stall so you're almost all
eyes closed in a calm state
but you're going down deeper and deeper
and deeper as you hear the bowel and the
waves and it's giving out the sounds
that it's giving out
and this is what I personally do three
times
so when when I cannot hear the bell in
the faint distance anymore I then Strike
It Again
try not to open your eyes but if you're
worried about what you can hit it in the
right place or not then just slightly
crack your eyes open so you can see
striker in the mouth
in time you will not need to do this
so you're going to go listening to the
sounds
turn on the force that yourself going
deeper and deeper but you're going to go
deep inside yourself Beyond the Mat into
the Earth
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
when you hear the Bell no more
just keep
trying to hold that position of depth
and well with your Kennels
foreign
as if
you've been rocked
in my panic
you may feel claustrophobic
the deeper we go means the more we let
go
and the more we let go
the further we will go
into another Realm
the Realms have not always being in
control on the human plane that we have
to live with on a daily basis
but we'll be going to
a place
where enlightenment
can be
seen
heard
unobtained
sometimes it will take a lifetime to
reach this point
Others May find it quickly
if you're in a rush to find it
you will possibly take you a lot longer
the biggest advice I can
part
to you is
enjoy each stage of the doing
and try not to look for an outcome
because
I find that every time I sit
what you're on now
I come out of it feeling refreshed
so in this wonderful calm place that you
should hopefully be with your eyes
closed
not able to hear your breath even
because it's such a wonderful place to
be
and when you're ready and only when
you're ready
feel yourself coming up from the base
and telling yourself that you're coming
up back from the base or wherever you've
been
back into your normal natural human body
feeling your body film up
and becoming yourself again
you may want to take an extra breath
perhaps through the mouth or through the
nose
[Music]
You may wish to decide
relax as you slowly open your eyes
and come back
to the womb
and your daughter
thank you for allowing me to tell you on
this journey